mariah evans writes a few weeks ago
ended up with a at the vet with my 14
year old dog Henry he's had cancer for
the pet I think we need some sad Hope
Christ man first the sad frog song now
the dead dog
this works out though yeah dog comes
back from the dead zombie dog sometimes
dead is better a few weeks ago I ended
up at the vet with my 14 year old dog
Henry yet cancer for the past three
years
okay that's worse than the Frey girl
thing you are going to hell ending I can
laugh because it's a good ending then he
started looking
you're [ __ ] mean one mr. Grinch with
my 14 year old I can't do that
he said can't he's that cop so for the
past three what he started limping
we thought it had spread to his bones
while I waited for the results of the
vet my dog and I listened to Hollywood
babble-on
to keep me calm laughing it kept me
laughing while I felt like crying thank
you guys for your podcast and for
bringing lots of laughs to my life
Henry's doing much better now no thanks
to Ralph and all my worrying was for
nothing
now I listen to the new podcast with
Henry but I noticed something strange
that he does in here so well anymore
about this dog man everything's out of
his [ __ ] broken and [ __ ] my dog lucky
the other thing goes 14 cut Henry a
break yes I going an old RV he doesn't
hear so well anymore but when Kevin does
his creepy sexy voice say oh I was
hardness he gets up and stares at the
music player and wags his tail
I thought it was odd enough to write
into you guys could Ralph get Kevin to
talk dirty to my dog thanks for all the
fun
Mariah Evan yes so for Henry the
fourteen-year-old art of hearing cancer
dog could you please talk dirty to him
he'll be happy and wag his tail
I'm only considering this because I have
an old dog too man and I know like you
know there's not much you could do for
him but talk them off I guess that's
right Henry
oh let me see your [ __ ] dog say [ __ ]
you won't know what I mean red thing
they're like I got one of those lipstick
I want to put on my filthy clown makeup
Henry see you in doggy that's a [ __ ]
good thing man have you ended with a dog
go good to have it done
[Music]
you
[Music]